this windswept hilltop is Old Sarum in
Wiltshire
it's an enormous Iron Age hill fort and
you know actually the best way to see it
is not from down here this is one of the
most important historical sites in
southern England an Iron Age
fortification from more than 2,000 years
ago then in the 11th century a castle
was built for William the Conqueror and
the Catholic Church built a cathedral
here you can see the foundations of all
of those surviving centuries later this
was a thriving bit of England but it
fell from grace there's a lot of
complicated reasons why but one of the
main ones is and he windswept hilltop is
a terrible place for a Cathedral much as
that looks impressive and you can
dominate a landscape that brings a
number of problems with it supplies of
water you know from wells were just not
adequate to support a large population
and even to the extent that they
actually needed to buy the water that
they needed to drink when the way there
isn't good the wind is blowing over the
rain is coming at you when thunderstorms
are going it's a very very bad place as
well as that the local bishop Raja fell
out with the new king Stephen and that's
in a period of history when falling out
with the king was very serious indeed
Robert falls out with the king he falls
out with pretty much everyone that is
the price you pay for being active
within within politics only within
religion and he plays the game at very
high levels and he does come crashing
down there's also an institutional
problem that Kings men in the castle and
the bishops men around the cathedral you
get a few references to conflict there
where for example a procession of clergy
was was stopped by some of the king's
soldiers behaving childishly that they
would easily go look we don't want any
more of this begging the Pope to release
them from all of this and the Pope say
absolutely you can have somewhere that
will be all your own down at the bottom
and giving giving them licence for it so
the clergy moved a couple of miles away
to a new cathedral in a place that would
eventually become known as Salisbury the
buildings here start to fall into
disrepair and the once busy town
declined and declined and declined but
despite that for some reason the
landowners of Old Sarum were invited to
send to representative
to Parliament this was a 14th century
now when the rules of Parliament were
still being written
and the reason why they were invited is
a bit of a mystery historians still
aren't sure one of the things that
modern archaeology is starting to tell
us quite a bit about is whether there
was stuff going on outside the hill fort
on lower ground that we don't know about
that
that's nearer into Old Sarum than the
new city of Salisbury there's a very
strong likelihood that while the hill
fort itself had been abandoned there was
a bit more settlement further down and
probably in the later Middle Ages it
wouldn't have been regarded as such a
complete nonsense of two MPs being
elected for a place with no population
at all
so this Hill had two members of
parliament and that didn't change for
centuries it didn't change as the
population dwindled it didn't change
when King Henry the 8th to signed over
possession of all the buildings to a
local official to order them dismantled
and used for building material by the
17th century no one lived here but you
didn't have to live here to vote anyone
who was nominated by the landowner has
been one of the tenants in this area
that was enough and of course they voted
for the person who nominated them so
this Hill became a rotten borough if you
owned the land then you and a friend or
whichever two people he chose had seats
in parliament representing basically
just yourself and if you were
particularly rich and well-connected you
might own a couple of other boroughs
nearby which would elect your friends
meanwhile places like the city of
Manchester eventually growing to a
quarter of a million people had no one
representing them at all for centuries
by the 19th century it was clear that
something had to be done but how do you
change something like that how do you
convince people with power to give up
that power public outrage radicals
protests including one where 60,000
people were attacked by the military
which came to be known as the Peterloo
massacre in May 1832 riots broke out
when the third attempt at a reform bill
was blocked in Parliament and Britain
likely came closer to rebel
after all the French Revolution was
still very much in living memory then in
short the Reformers won and historians
can argue about how much of that was
political wrangling by the people who
gained power and how much of that was
the very real threat of violent
revolution when the dust settled the law
was changed the rotten boroughs were
abolished and there were 130 new seats
in parliament voting was only for men
with land or money though it took until
1918 about to become all men and some
women and it was 1928 before it was all
adults these days parliamentary
boundaries are drawn by an independent
group based on population this hill is
managed by a charity called English
heritage and one member of parliament
for Salisbury represents this whole area
and the roughly 70,000 people who live
in it it's important to remember that
history is fractal you could spend days
or years or a lifetime studying
everything that happened over those few
days in 1832 or you could sum up
centuries in a few minutes but there's
one thing that Old Sarum shows very
clearly it is extremely difficult to
convince people with power to give it up
willingly
thanks to English heritage for letting
me film at Old Sarum you can find out
more about them and about visiting here
on their website the link is in the
description
you